and they get all upset when people apply
for the banks but loans why are you
taking the Ducks place money I paid good
tax
then you don't you pay very very little
hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video we're gonna be talking
about bounced back loans you may well be
eligible for fifty thousand pound loan
from the government now this has been
talked about quite a lot in different
newspapers on different YouTube channels
for the last couple months I haven't
really said too much about it because I
just thought what isn't it obvious
what a bounce-back loan is you can find
it by just googling what a bounce-back
loan is and you can check your
eligibility very very easily the problem
is is when I don't speak and I stay
quiet lots of other people start
speaking and lots of other people start
speaking nonsense and there have been so
much stuff said about bounce-back loans
that it's completely ludicrous and
untrue I just wanted to go back to
basics talk about what a bounce-back
loan is maybe explain whether you're
eligible for one or not can you invest
in property can you not what's the
purpose how does it work when's it start
when's it start what's the interest so
hopefully you find this video really
helpful so firstly what is it
bounce-back loan and who's before it is
for businesses who have been hit but
like Kovac 19 who have been struggling
over these last few months and they're
possibly going to continue to struggle
as well and the government have been
giving money in form of bounced back
loans to help sustain those types of
businesses if your business is
absolutely brand-new you're probably
still eligible and if your business is a
really large business you're probably
also eligible they're very very easy to
get a lot of my students have been
getting bounce back loans have been
applying in about 20 minutes
and they've been getting the money
within a couple of days into their bank
account so they're kind of interesting
loans and they're also very very cheap
loans there's really importantly to say
this this is not free money because it
is a loan so by very definition you have
to pay it back it is a very cheap loan
bounce-back loans you have to give
nothing back for the first 12 months so
for 12 months you pay nothing back and
then after 12 months you have five
years to pay the money back and they
charge you two percent interest per year
that is cheaper than mortgage rights
that is absolutely ridiculous there's no
option to do interest-only payments
which means that every month you need to
pay your little bit of interest plus
some of the money back so how much will
they give you in form of a bounce-back
loan the maximum they'll give you is
fifty thousand pounds a lot of people
get a balance but alone for ten thousand
pounds a lot do 450 and anywhere in
between so the question is should you
get a bounce-back loan and the answer is
yes if you're eligible for one and
you're a smart businessperson or a smart
investor and you could take that money
and you could turn it into more money
which is effectively what a businessman
and investor does then I would say 100%
take advantage of the situation and get
a bounce-back loan I've never known the
government give loans like this before
in my lifetime I don't know ever there
ever gonna do it again I don't think
it's gonna be around for a long time so
if you're eligible and if you're smart
and if you know how to invest money and
use money in your business I would say
absolutely 100% yes now whilst I don't
agree with people that are missing
forming people and saying that it's free
money and you don't have to give it back
I mean absolutely crazy at the same time
people over here are saying it's selfish
to get a bounce-back loan and it's
greedy and unless you're on your knees
and you're absolutely struggling and
your business is gonna go bust you
shouldn't apply for a bank back line
because it's taxpayers money it's our
money that your that is also completely
nonsense because whilst the loan is
taxpayers money because the government
are giving you out here's the thing that
just freaks me out
you're paying it back so mr. taxpayer
who's all upset about people getting
bounced back loans that's more money by
the way people would say that usually
don't make much money anyway so their
tax contributions are very very very
small and then they get all upset when
people apply for the banks but loans why
are you taking the Ducks place money I
paid good tax
I mean you don't you pay very very
little and the people that are taking
the taxpayers money are using
to make more money or paying the money
back with interest and then the more
money that they've made they're paying
more tax
so taking backs back loans as long as
you are eligible and you don't lie on
the form to get abouts background it's
actually helping the taxpayers and it's
helping give the government more money
so if you have a business even a
property business and you're eligible
for a bounce back alone do it and do it
now make sure of course that you can
afford to pay it back because after
twelve months you're going to start
having to pay it back slowly
you've got five years to do it but it's
not interest only so you're gonna be
here for a year plan carefully but this
is what I always say
and this is what really gets to me
because people say Samuel encourages
debts I mean I'm like yeah I encourage
that as long as it is good debt and is
no different with bounce-back loan
people don't get people to understand
the difference between good debt and bad
debt good debt is really good bad debt
is really bad and if you're applying for
a bounce-back alone which is debt could
you have to pay it back as long as it's
good debt ie
you use it to make more money then it's
good and go and do it and sometimes
people say can you buy a property with a
bounced back line okay now I know people
are doing this I know there's a lot of
investors that are getting bounced back
loans and they're buying properties with
it it's something that's a little bit
sketchy because most lenders so if
you're getting a bounce-back loan and
then you're trying to get a mortgage as
well so you're using the bounce back
long as your deposit most lenders aren't
going to be very happy with that they're
not going to like the bounce back alone
being form of a deposit so it's not the
easiest to go buy a property you there
are some lenders that you can't do it
with you can use it as a deposit and get
a bridging loan and then do the BRR
strategy by refurbished refinance and
then refinance and get back you you can
do that I don't know if I would endorse
or encourage doing that because I know
there's a lot of lenders that aren't
keen on it but listen here's the bottom
line as long as you're honest when you
fill out forms when you take out the
bounce-back loan you're going to have
terms and conditions with that loan
they're going to say you can do this and
you can't do this great when you take
out a mortgage you're gonna have terms
and conditions with that loan so if you
take out a bridging loan or a mortgage
I bounced back alone as long as you're
not breaking any of the terms and
conditions my opinion doesn't matter
Joe Bloggs whose opinion on Facebook
trolling everybody telling them how
greedy they are taking loans and doing
this that the other it's no one's
business what whether you get bounced
back alone is no one's business what you
do with the bounce background is no
one's business as long as you don't
break the law as long as when you take
out these loans you don't go against the
terms and conditions that you agreed to
then do whatever the heck you can to
make you money and when you make money
you'll pay your taxes you'll be a good
citizen and no one can moan with that
people do people love to moan and people
what I've seen in this whole Cove in 19
episodes are struggling and it's just
absolutely saddened me because right now
we should be standing together because
without business people we have no
economy and with no economy the world
does not look good so my advice would be
whether you get a loan whether you don't
get a loan whether you buy property
whether you don't buy property mind your
own business
support people and just be a positive
person encourage people listen I hope
this video has been helpful hope it's
been informative if it has drop me a
like drop a comment let me know your
thoughts subscribe turn the notification
about on and I'll afford to seeing you
next time